40 years in the lgbtq lifestyle he had
friends he had Community it was his
identity and then he left it all behind
why why would you leave your whole
Social Circle your whole life behind for
what Wayne says it was Jesus he became a
Christian but does Christianity really
give you the power to overcome to to
choose to not live out your lgbtq
lifestyle or or desires or does it not
is it just a facade today we're
discussing four flavors of lgbtq
Christianity and Wayne's going to show
you how only one of them is actually
biblical I'd like to have a conversation
about you know the the different
categorizations that are going on as it
relates to um the homosexual topic today
you know within the church environment
it used to be that we would look at the
Bible and we go well either it's sin or
you know I have a different idea and
that's where you would leave it now
whole new uh um language has been
engineered and so it's really not
necessary that you have to know this
language but if you're going to have a
conversation with somebody who's um my
age or younger you know it might be
helpful to know some of the things that
are floating around this is pretty
common for people you know probably
between the ages of 18 and 35 today many
of them are already familiar with this
but it's it can be very confusing for
somebody who who is leaving the LGBT
world and it could be also confusing for
somebody on the outside or somebody from
inside of Christianity who's viewing uh
the LGB topic to try to figure out you
know what what am what am I really
looking at today so it really starts off
with what is called um side a and side a
is the belief that God made people um
gay they they were born this way way um
He blesses uh marital unions of the same
gender so this is just full acceptance
of everything basically absolutely yeah
they don't there's there's no no one
would ever consider leaving the LGBT
world you know this is this and they're
fine with God and they're God's fine
with them and then that's what we see in
a lot of uh churches today as well and
specifically maybe the more mega
churches you know where this happens
their only idea on this where of
anything being wrong would be the idea
that uh from a Biblical standpoint that
God would be condemning homosexuality in
the sense of ancient uh sinful practices
you know like uh child molestation or
child sacrifice or um anything that
would be outside of a a loving
monogamous relationship so so how how do
these Christians explain the Bible
version that's directly speak against it
well that would fall into queer Theory
so the idea that Sodom and Gomorrah was
destroyed for sexual depravity um they
would say no homosexuality was destroyed
because of lack of
hospitality and what about 2 Corinthians
6:9-11 well the the the word homosexual
wasn't really introduced to the Bible
until
1946 and so the the Greek and the Hebrew
words there would you know that they use
those to say that you know it would mean
it meant something different like the it
was a man who was um who was molesting a
boy only that's really not what happens
when you go and do the research on the
Greek and the Hebrew words and it says
in the Bible specifically man shall not
lay with men yes so that would be a
somebody who's born
heterosexual would would it would be
wrong for him to lay with another man
but for somebody who is born homosexual
then God doesn't have a problem with
that yeah I just find interesting that
it seems like and this is common within
Christianity regarding any scripture we
Tred to interpret that it's interpreted
outside of the Bible so you appli the
hermeneutic of your choice to make room
for whatever it is you want to hang on
to and not give up that's interesting
they're saying from second Corinthians
that that language wasn't in the Bible
at that time but they use that same line
of logic when it comes to Jonathan and
and D David's relationship they're
putting that language into the story
right yeah even though there's no sexual
relationship in the description of that
relationship yeah and then in Leviticus
it would be thought that they were there
were prostitutes and that there was
taking place in front of the false god
mik and so I'm thinking so if it was a
monogamous same sex relationship in
front of a true God does that I don't
quite get that so so side a is just you
know this idea that I was born that way
side B um is what some uh people believe
today that would identify themselves as
a gay Christian that they will go with
the idea that they have same-sex
orientation um and that they believe in
God's word and that they believe in his
ideals and that that isn't going to
change who they are so they are going to
identify uh with a gay orientation you
know uh being a gay Christian and that
they will uphold um the teachings of
God's word there's a bleeding that
happens a little bit between columns
here but the most of the people at least
on paper inside B would be celibate
individuals they would not believe in in
gay marriage and they equate this same
seex sin to be equal to any other sin
and so therefore um they don't they
don't think that it's a wise idea to
talk to somebody about how it came about
that that would be more harmful to that
individual and it digs up too much of
their past and they don't want to do any
damage and so they just move forward
within the church identifying as gay
Christians um so that's the thing of of
focusing on the person and not the the
sin condition the condition okay but yet
they still celebrate gay identity yes
that's odd yeah so in fact this is
honestly in the denomination where I am
um this is hugely celebrated um
maintaining LGBT identify and still
identifying by your your denomination
that you know it's like saying you're an
LGBT Christian and and so that really
opens the flood floodgates of of uh
being um suspicious about what is
taking place and what's not taking place
a lot of people will say in
denominations today that a gay Christian
or an LGBT Christian should be able to
hold Church leadership and everything
but um my question is well who's going
around with a flashlight and seeing you
know who's practicing the behavior and
who's not it it is really ambiguous to
to throw the idea that you can be LGBT
and Christian and not practice the
behavior because this side B doesn't
just by saying that you're LGBT and
Christian doesn't indicate to me that
you are being celibate I guess my
question would be why keep the in this
case the label at the Forefront only to
not utilize it so it's like as if you're
dangling the Temptation you're still
hanging on to the ideation and you know
that if you do that it's kind of
actually what AA did and so you know
once an alcoholic always an alcoholic
might be 40 years sober but you still
identify as an alcoholic however in the
Bible God doesn't see you that when you
become redeemed you become a new
creation in him he doesn't say well here
comes my alcoholic son you know he says
here comes my redeemed child my new
creation in Christ today and so I feel
that side B is not fully um encompassing
the identity that Jesus has to offer
them and when you hang on to ideations
from your past or that you're not
actually engaging with if you put such
an emphasis there it's probably a matter
of time before you do start engaging
that's what I was going to say I would
really be curious and don't really know
if there's any way to look at numbers
but how many people stay inside B for a
long period of time so there's a study
that was done by one of the people that
I interviewed for my film uh the freedom
project in uh she was attending a
conference in um in Poland and she uh
was aware of a study that had been done
and she has sent the study actually to
me and she said that there are those who
identify they or they've done the
studies to show that those who identify
as LGBT and Christian that given a
particular point in
time um how they monitor this over the
course of time that at some point that
LGBT Christian is still making a an
acceptance of some kind of same-sex
Behavior within them ideation that's
going on that that they believe that
somehow God doesn't mind or or that he
would actually approve and so there
there is that it proves that there's
that danger of identifying that way
because you're you're making exceptions
what what else do you think or is there
something else that someone could be
holding on to that's not sexual but they
would still identify as uh same seex
attraction that makes sense because same
seex attraction is linked to the ACT
correct but they're not doing the act so
they still have but they still have the
label so what are they holding on to
especially if they're saying this is not
my identity my identity is in Christ but
that's always been perplexing to me too
I haven't really been able to grasp
fully because I'm thinking for some
people it's Community but then if you're
not associated with the community
because you don't want to do the act so
you're not holding on to that so so like
what is it is there even words for that
maybe it's something like an addiction
like you know same sex that might be
something that they're holding on to oh
so they thinking I'm not doing the ACT
but I'm watching okay interesting yeah
that that that could fire up yeah um in
your mind that you might identify a
certain way even though you weren't
going out and and I think that also
speaks to Christ Christ is a All or
Nothing um person you know God it's like
you choose you choose Satan you choose
sin you choose destruction or you choose
me uh Christ life of complete
restoration leaving the old behind and
stepping into the new and so yeah
leaving that label there holding on to
anything having to do with that past
last while still trying to live out your
truth there's always going to be that
conflict there yeah um after side B
There is what is called PEX and PEX
claims that same sex attraction and
Temptation in itself is a
sin
[Music]
um that's difficult for me to Grapple
with um there are people who have
promoted this idea some of the
testimonies that I've listened to have
been really encouraging and I've been
inspired by and then they come to this
point where they state that um that
Simply Having the attraction or being
tempted is in itself sin so basically a
calvinistic sort of viewpoint right so
when Jesus was tempted by Satan in the
desert was he sinning yeah right like he
was probably hungry and he probably
thought I would really like that bread
it would be really nice but I'm not
going to take it because I know this is
you know like God says it is written uh
man shall not live by bread alone but by
every word that proceeds from the mouth
of God he knew he like I I'm I'm doing
this for for my father I'm doing this
for Humanity I'm fasting I'm not giving
it to Satan's Temptations but I'm sure
he was hungry so doesn't mean that he
was hungry that he sinned right and so I
don't think it's a Temptation like a sin
sorry like like you guys are still um
attracted to men you know so but it
depends on what do you do with it how
many people are married who see an
attractive person in the street depends
on what you do with it yes are you going
to be like
wow I don't know I'm just saying like
are you going to be like that or are you
going to be like well that's an
attractive person God has made
I love my husband I love my wife you
know yeah look at my wife look at my
husband or whatever if you're male or
female you're married you know do you
switch your mind to something else I
think I I I yeah I agree I don't think
that being tempted is a sin it is
considered that those experiencing these
attractions must repent because God's
intent for all people is heterosexuality
and that gays can be cured
so there are those who would then make
that comment then ra right being cured
being a process that they like have
arrived I am cured and I have had
conversations I was on a radio um
interview once where a lesbian ex
lesbian said that she was cured and then
the moderator for the interview began to
tell me you see wayne so you know
there's still hope for you so even
though I was holding up a Redemptive
view on homosexuality
I was still thinking well because I I
was feeling like well because I still
experienced same seex attraction that I
must not be converted and so it really
made me feel awful about myself and um
so I want to encourage you know people
today that that remember that Jesus was
tempted all the way to the cross and you
don't have to engage um and you don't
have to ponder Temptation for a long
time because you know Christ asks us to
surrender our Temptations and give them
over to cam he says down every thought
and every imagination you know that
disagrees with him or dishonors him but
you know I would I would begin to feel
like I would have if I was like Catholic
that I would constantly have to have a
Rosary in my hand and and just you know
because the the amount of times that
attraction and those ideas come to mind
are so frequent that I could never get
out of this hell that I'm in but because
of of Jesus and because of the fact that
he promises you know forgiveness yes I
do think that if you if you Ponder
something or if you consider something
or if you're walking down the road of
you know thinking well then not only is
that person attractive but if they were
naked and and you go down this road that
that's a you know a dangerous place to
be these people would leave behind all
same-sex attractions and um admirably
pursue heterosexual relationships well
the fact is that nearly 99% of those who
leave the LGBT World um they remain
celibate but they also remain single
um while I still you know consider that
marriage you know and celibacy both are
are Godly that is interesting because if
I think about how many people I know
that have left the LGBT
community I know of probably less than
hundred but I know of several people
that are married and with families and
stuff so I wonder if wonder if it's
changing that statistic so side I just
wonder uh used to be samex attracted
yeah that's interesting see I don't my
my probably that would be because of my
generation and maybe I don't see that
much and I'm not um in touch as much
with the younger
statistics um as it relates to
that but I would say this for those I do
know some who have used marriage as all
I need to do is get married and this
thing will fix itself and I know people
that have come out on the other side of
that who have said oo I didn't really
think that out real well and you know
the accusation will come from the LGBT
community today that God does not
approve of mixed orientation marriages
and for a long time I was like what does
that mean well it means that somebody is
still gay uh but they're trying to live
as a married person whereas what I would
say today is that there may be those who
experience same seex attraction ction
who might have been better off to remain
single and celibate than trying to
manifest something that is only going to
bring about further pain for themselves
and for their spouse yeah so caution to
to young people to make sure that that
they are led by God into the marriage
rather than going ah this will fix
everything yeah and this is this
position of sidex believe also that
Sodom and Gomorrah was destroyed largely
because of of homosexuality and that it
was detestable it
the Sodom and Gomorrah was destroyed for
homosexuality but it wasn't just
homosexuality and this is where I think
a lot of people get hung up the
overarching thing that uh Sodom and
Gomorrah was just destroyed over was
Pride yeah and there was you know there
was a lot of lot of secal depravity that
was taking place that went beyond um a
homosexual nature then there is Side Y
and this is probably somebody who has a
combination of side B and side x um they
both agree that same-sex relationships
are wrong side y focuses on an identity
in Jesus Christ so there's no need to
identify by their sexual orientation and
they are called to Holiness rather than
a label of sexual
orientation um the goal uh is not to
ultimately become heterosexual but to
become more like Jesus Christ and they
believe that God works uniquely in each
person's life with an outcome that is
always in agreement with his word and
that's what I like to share with people
there you know God has a unique plan for
each and everyone's life it may include
marriage it may not uh you may end up
being single you may have a a number of
scenarios there but it will always we
always want to go back to the fact that
it would agree with God's word and not
take AC exception to God's word so
there's not complete agreement between
these columns some would be adverse to
any kind of of counseling uh thinking
that the focus of counseling and
behavior
modification um which is in their minds
constitutes conversion therapy I have as
you know well some know some don't I'm I
am in the middle of a documentary that
I'm making as it relates to the topic of
conversion therapy um the definition of
conversion therapy today uh by the LGBT
community and by Websters is anything
that suggests that you live differently
than how you feel wow that just opens a
whole can of worms so it used to be
thought that you know aversive
techniques like shock therapy immersing
immersion into ice cold baths and things
like that was um what was practiced in
the line of conversion therapy but those
things are already criminal haven't been
practiced for like 70 years but today
the LGBT Community throws like the power
of prayer or talk therapy uh into this
uh category of conversion therapy so it
is now criminal in 31 regions around the
world um wow the definition is really
that broad yeah yeah yeah cuz you think
someone if they have bad thoughts and
they go to therapy for help and it's an
issue for the therapist to help them if
it has anything to do with their
sexuality yes so I interviewed a gay
pastor in New York City U Brandon
Robertson um he told me that I said well
this sounds to me like
that if you are
criminalizing this so-called conversion
therapy and being able to talk to a
therapist that you're holding the LGBT
community captive hostage and he said no
they you know they have the right if
they choose to leave the LGBT community
on their own that's fine but to any
Pastor or any mental health specialist
that would claim that they could assist
in changing somebody's sexual
orientation they should have their
license revoked even if the person wants
help in that AB
absolutely what is it about this you
know what I mean it goes I'll tell you
I'll tell you what it is so if I suggest
to you that change is possible and
you're identifying to me as
LGBT if I'm going to agree with what
you've said to me that's an natural
Assumption of guilt on my part and I
won't be able to live with that unless I
make you feel that you should not have
suggested that to begin with wow so and
then the attack on freedom second to
that exactly is is the point that it's
robbing a person of their personal
freedom and it's destroying our
religious freedom at the same time yeah
and you know there are already movements
today you know as we found that the the
black judge I forget her name on the
Supreme Court um was saying that Jackson
yes I believe that's her name is she
said the the First Amendment today is
hamstringing our decision-making process
I'm like well yes it is it's for a
reason too it's so that we can preserve
a person's you know individual freedoms
and so there are lots of move movements
out there today that are seeking to make
us more of a Marxist government rather
than having the freedom of choice and so
that's the purpose of the documentary is
to help bring further education and
Clarity to people about what's going on
but to help us you know stand for our
religious freedom and our personal
freedom to choose and the psychologists
that I interviewed that identify as
Christian all of them said to me you
know we only see people that come to us
out of their choice and we ask them what
are your goals what are you hoping to
accomplish and so if somebody's wanting
to seek a relationship with someone of
the opposite sex you know the
psychologists can begin to talk about
what their past has been like what were
the contributing factors that led up to
where they are for many of them it has
been traumatic
physical that's taken place how to sort
through some of that um your just your
thought of your own gender and how
you've either um idolized it because you
don't feel that you qualified you know
as being a a authentic male could
contribute to some of your ideations
about wanting you know a masculine male
that's going to give you affirmation
there's just all kinds of different
roads you can go down someone might
think this is ridiculous but is I'm
asking a serious question the the lgbtq
community who are against convergent
therapy are they against it in the
reverse if someone a heterosexual person
goes to therapy looking to go into the
lgbtq community they were for that yes
so anything that would be a convert
which would be conversion oh so come on
in but don't leave choice you can come
our Direction you can't so i' like
that's why I say it feels like that
they're holding people hostage and you
know I have people that are not even
Christian who I've learned of that are
either Buddhist or Muslim who have gone
to a a psychologist and said you know I
don't want to live this life anymore I
would like to live differently and and I
just feel kind of locked in can you help
me I even asked you know to Brandon
Robertson the gay Pastor um so I said I
have a friend of mine who experienced
um at the age of four years old so can
you not see that this was an incident
that occurred that was traumatic that
would have brought on the ideations for
him to feel like maybe he was gay in his
future you know as he in the years ahead
and he goes no regardless of that you
know that man was born
gay and so I think that there that's a
troubling concept I I don't think that
would hold up real well among all these
sides uh there is not total agreement
and some uh bleed between the columns
and this only adds to me to chaos and
confusion in the church and we know that
God is is not a god of chaos and
confusion but the enemy is it seems to
be an interpretation issue that's why
there's all this divide and it makes it
even more difficult for someone wanting
to leave the lifestyle when they find a
church and they think they're going to
go in there to get help and then it
might be something that's not biblical
or it could be something that they don't
agree with a complete side that and it
just adds to the confusion and they may
just give up and go back yeah so the
lingo is trying to lay a precedent over
everything so it begins to replace
biblical Concepts and I think that's
what the danger is in these different
sides while there are these different
sides there are also different streams
that some of them are um congruent to
the different sides in in question so I
just quickly review some of those
the Revel uh stream would be again God
Made Me This Way um God blesses samesex
unions and the resist position would be
side b um again that I am going to bank
on my sexual orientation rather than an
orientation in Jesus Christ and identify
by by that and then the um it's
interesting how you depicted the logo
because lgbtq is like Paramount huge
over the identity of being a Christian
yeah in that in those categories and
this actually came from Jason Thompson
uh from Portland Fellowship he developed
these columns and these streams um but
they're very well known like the
different sides and um it's it's
interesting to go through this if you
study this you know on your screen and
you can see some at the bottom of this
there are some suggested people most of
these people are known in secular
society um for um who they they are and
they would they would buy into these
Concepts the renounced position which is
where I felt that I was residing for 12
years of my Ministry was that I let go
of my LGBT my gay identity and accepted
that I had a new identity in Jesus
Christ uh but here in this column even
is where some of those ideas that some
would still consider that attraction is
sin so so this just gives you kind of a
thumbnail sketch of each column and and
kind of people that are thinking that
are out there today but by and large
these are people who are um
denying themselves their Natures for
Jesus Christ and wanting to live for him
and um be that New Creation in him the
rebuild
position is a little bit of a Step
Beyond that these are people who were
definitely in the renounced position but
now they they want everything that God
intended for them so by that's where
you're at right you by conversion I
would say I want whatever God wants for
me and so if you were to put somebody in
front of me that I would fall in love
with that's of the opposite sex of
course I would Embrace that because that
would be part of what God's plan is he
hasn't revealed that particular plan to
me I I don't know that he will I do
think that he is indicated to me you've
already had enough Intimacy in your life
from a from a human standpoint what you
really need now is an intimacy you know
with Jesus Christ yeah not not a
intimacy but a relational exactly the
common denominator of all these uh
categories is is God they all believe in
God they're all Christians so he he's
present even despite the differences or
the
misinterpretations when it comes to
someone who let's put a scenario someone
who is of the rebuild theology who isend
attending a a revel
Church like okay now what type of a
thing do you leave how do you Minister
how can we make it practical I would say
that um you know you said they all have
a belief in God I believe that they all
have an association with God and so that
you know true belief in God would be
wanting to adapt to his his will his his
plan and so if you find yourself in a
church which is mainly in this Revel
position or side a
position I would want to say
how strong is my faith in Jesus Christ
how can I weather this storm am I strong
enough in my faith in him that I believe
that he's Place me here that I might
draw others to Jesus Through me or do I
need to look for a different
congregation that is going to be uh like
I need more spiritual food in my own
life so I need to to get into a either a
renounce or a reed rebuild kind of
position and so here even in this
rebuild position is where some in the
field of psychology or mental health U
counseling say they might be accused of
conversion therapy but what they're
really trying to be therefore is that
individual would come into a place in
their relationship with Jesus that they
would experience the least amount of
tempt same-sex Temptation in their lives
and and and getting everything that that
God intended for them rather than just
constantly in the renounce column saying
oh I have this attraction I'm sorry
please forgive me and leave me it there
there's hope in Jesus right that that's
basically what we're discussing here
that if somebody is in the lgbtq
lifestyle right now wants to come out
says I want to follow Jesus they will
come across uh various streams like
you're saying but but the ultimate idea
is that and Truth in the Bible is that
there is hope in Jesus he can transform
our hearts he has transformed you guys'
hearts and what I find so beautiful
is that you know God created right he
created that intimacy and it is one of
the most powerful things you can
experience when God allows it inside a
and and and gives he gifts it to us in
inside a heterosexual marriage
situation but you guys have both
experienced this you know outside of
that in in a a homosexual relationship
and yet there's so many strong chemicals
in that and so many strong attachments
yet you guys would say I'd rather not
experience it for the rest of my life
but to have a relationship with Jesus
that that is more powerful than all
those experiences that tells me that
Jesus truly heals truly saves and is
worth setting everything aside for
because it is that healing bonding and
fulfilling that whole that all of us
have inside our hearts when I go back to
the idea or the concept of the great
controversy and that there is a war you
know there was a war in heaven when I
came to Jesus Christ I had to go back
and realize that the War Began in heaven
and now there's a war on Earth about who
who is really going to win out in this
is it going to be the enemy of of Jesus
who is Satan or will Jesus win and the
Bible tells us that Jesus knows us
before we were born and we know
prophetically across time in the Bible
we're living in you know as is said the
last days and so I
believe for the particularly for the
person who may be watching who is still
saying why God I would have never ever
desired to have this in my life why do I
have to have this this Albatross hanging
around my neck of of same seex
attraction I believe that that God knew
you before you were born and chose you
to be able to say to the enemy as a
witness for Jesus Jesus Christ look you
can even tempt him with same-sex
attraction just like Jesus was tempted
in the desert with with with food he's
allowing us to be tempted to to malign
what God intended um which was intimacy
between a man and a woman but tries to
put a counterfeit in his place and yet
Jesus says I have soldiers of the Cross
people who are going to believe and and
according to my word who are going to
surrender themselves and deny themselves
for me and so on Judgment Day he can say
to the enemy look even though you did
what you did they still chose me that is
powerful it's a perspective change it's
like instead of looking at it from a
perspective of suffering it's one of joy
of of of being in service with the Lord
being on his army being literally used
as an example of of despite the devil's
Temptation I'm standing for CH Warrior
wow that's amen um there are if you're
looking for Christian Counseling um I
can certainly recommend some people who
are in that field today that still have
their licenses and I pray will always
hold on to them I'll give you my contact
information but you can reach me at No
Greater Love
KN uh just like you get to know Jesus No
Greater Love at
comcast.net and I'm happy to share more
information with you there
[Music]
oh